[Music]
in then don't hire me news don't do it
that [ __ ] hug submitted by IKEA
instructions oh yeah easy yeah building
that drink fig for my office right now
oh really a fired Amazon worker with
bowel disease is now suing over a lack
of bathroom breaks IBS damn I got IBS so
I live with a BST then I got a [ __ ] like
a [ __ ] sometimes okay okay okay
when you got the bubble goes like oh
[ __ ] you get all the time like I had it
like a lot when I was in high school
tell about the bad stuff oh so it's like
an all-access pass to bathrooms so no
matter where you are you go in and you
just run out you just take a [ __ ] oh oh
it's like idea that's funny do it it's
kind of like it you know in the movies
were the cops it's like don't worry I'm
[ __ ] FBI and they kick the person off
the car start taking their [ __ ] okay
I'm gonna do it we do movies knows what
damn ibf movie guy we do one call
mission and poops a bull that's kind of
the same thing oh yeah that was Bart
with IBS no no that was another one dude
let's have some fun is so [ __ ] buddy
dude that [ __ ] beyond your time when you
made it done all right how long that's
how I feel about a lot of our skin
that's just so [ __ ] funny man
well what's key was that you guys did it
was long it was one year old ones used
to crack me up because you had a
moustache to get falling off and but it
was like different mustaches it was like
really oh no I know what you're talking
about yeah
oh the homeless guy
and then I was at a trash can and yeah
and the Gunther knew he's all [ __ ] up
because on purpose because he would get
up he would say something that must have
fall off and come back it would be back
on again we did that for a con a YouTube
contest man mmm that was like a song
yeah it was rigged like a [ __ ] -
yeah most views the most likes
everything and his other [ __ ] team
ones like 2008 days ago the beginnings
of YouTube rigging man [ __ ] up since
day one they started off crooked that's
why I was like not a surprise to me that
shit's going down I'm like come on man
come on man but I love you guys yeah I
love you guys yes
Nikolas is suing Amazon because he was
terminated after his supervisor said
that he was doing time stuff because he
kept going to the bathroom a lot
yeah he's still in time that's a dope
ass people [ __ ] art our time fast
yeah yeah you waste them what I mean me
for sure whenever I used to take shits
that like whatever job I was at now
forever like when I said take a [ __ ] at
footlocker I would just sit there for as
long as I could
yeah just eating up the time I used to
work in this kind of like a logistics
warehouse in the military and then I was
the one that was Manning like one entire
side so all the work that I need to get
done I would get it done hella quick but
then the Marine Corps you always got a
beard I like 5:00 a.m. no matter what so
I'll be done by like to piano my tired
as [ __ ] on my how can I take the nap and
so out both entrances I would always put
some noisy ass [ __ ] there like you've
got a squeaky chair that they would have
to move to open the drawer over and then
I would go and one of the crates that
had all these first aid kits and I'll
just get sit there and get my sleeping
bags put it on I'd be hella comfortable
and then as soon as I hear like one of
the noisy chairs moved and I get up
I'll help you that was a Tom steel there
uh this real quick you remind me of
something like a footlocker whenever
people would ask me to like if we'd like
do you have this shoe and I go gonna
have any size then can you call the
other store cuz we're supposed to do
that wait call yeah can you call can you
call like the Lakewood store the
Cerritos to see if they have it like
yeah cool and I mean [ __ ] busy though
you know like getting shoes for a bunch
of people I'd be like okay yeah yeah
hold on
I know be like over here it's loud in
the mall two ones running around said um
and I pretend like I'm waiting whatever
sorry while you're having it sent away
and then I'm like okay all right cool
thank you
no they didn't have your size sorry
let's come back about my shoes oh they
only have them in guy punch him in a row
we only got them in green that's all you
know it's been proven now that the
40-hour workweek actually contributes to
unproductive behavior hmm okay you're
just trying to get through it cuz it
takes more yeah it takes more energy to
like stretch the day out and then like
people usually get done with their job
like four hours or five hours or so and
they're just sitting there and like
trying to pretend to work or whatever to
keep their jobs and [ __ ] yeah and that's
the boredom is what kills people
hmm this is not getting enough work
they're getting like 20 hours of work
but the stretching it to 40 I mean most
people I mean I remember unless it was a
restaurant job those eight hours are not
being Spanish rose I'm done with my work
in two or three hours I mean she brought
even even at a restaurant job like we
would if it was a slow day which was you
know like a lot of times we sit there we
just talk at the little uh little you
put in the orders talking a little
monitors and then until a manager would
come by he's ten like we're wiping that
should do like in between lunch and
dinner and that's like the worst time
yeah is most estimators become
successful troublemakers always rise to
the top like [ __ ]
yeah like this [ __ ] with a little yeah
actually I never understood that
expression because like [ __ ] usually
sings yeah
because there's nothing in the [ __ ] out
of my head eating [ __ ] in the ocean
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh it's like that canister that they
have we could breathe into the ocean
that's [ __ ] big log of [ __ ] you go oh
dude I just made me think of Hawaii
right now man oh my god man what he
doesn't mean has asthma into it oh my
god
[Laughter]
quit quit so much [ __ ] someone takes it
please of time loading one I know you
can't get the wasn't see all of them
work at the bottom popping and there's
not the right one oh okay so he has
Crohn's disease crawls disease
yeah and and so because of that he is
just immediately you'll just come out of
nowhere where he needs to go take a [ __ ]
and so he that's not nice
he requested to be mmm he requested some
certain adjustments for his schedule or
like even where hit where he's located
at work I guess you could be closer to
the bathroom or if you can have like a
little extra like more personal time cuz
they get 20 minutes a week of personal
time a week yeah there's alisone right
yeah yeah I was I was pretty supposed to
be pretty rough yeah so then now he's
seeking three million dollars in damages
for lost wages and a quote significant
amplification of the symptoms oh he was
wrongfully terminated he's stressed out
he's sitting more yeah
wouldn't they be considered also kind of
like discrimination yeah that's what
he's saying that he believes that the
company violated the Americans with
Disabilities Act yeah cuz if someone had
like a diabetes and they needed to snack
on the job like you can't tell them no
yeah I don't give a damn about your
blood sugar yeah because they told him
like no we can't accommodate you because
then we have to do it for everyone but
not everyone with Crohn's disease you're
supposed to do it yeah [ __ ] dumbass
who's the manager there I bet you Jeff
Bezos was like man you stupid I bet you
Jeff Jeff Bezos was I can't deal with
this I just lost half a billion
you know this divorce no but I heard
that woman helped him out in everything
she had like a big hand in building a
famine on so she deserved it so she
deserves her as I read it Oh at first I
thought she was disliked bimbo and then
I saw another angle of them and I was
like all they're both ugly remember that
recent picture where they all come out
looking nice and [ __ ] and I'm like
that's one angle right in the same like
[ __ ] nice looking picture there's
another angle of her and I'm ashamed
that hot yeah and just someone posted
like a before-and-after of like what
they were as a couple well she was his
ride or die man they were ugly nerd
couple together right they [ __ ] they
[ __ ] made it and they became
beautiful together with the money for
genitals though like he's still kind of
the same well this is because one is
bigger than the other so he just looks
like he's suspicious all the time yeah
his brain looked like it got bigger to
his hair so I still [ __ ] yogi got rip
yoked yeah that sucks that he only got
you only get 20 minutes of person one
time cuz like man when I take shits like
each one is like 20 minutes
well I mean they give it no easy [ __ ] oh
it's [ __ ] session oh don't get excited
by full looking for is it handle already
is that all attempts flow were there no
other jobs in this area or like we're
there cuz I'm not sure but he's just
saying that he did disclose when they
hired him that kid does have Crohn's
disease and it's also an inconvenience
you don't mean like that time for me
finding one job CEO that like it's just
yeah I mean I'm not saying that he's not
in the wrong or anything but I bet if I
if I didn't like my workplace I would
just like look for another job he worked
at the Amazon called Center by the way
McCall sent yellow Amazon call center
though on are they I never called them
before yeah I didn't know that I just
emailed them oh so like I had a package
that somebody else picked up and I he
was just gone and I didn't get it and
then such the nicest customer service
ever they go well we'll just wait one
day and I'll give you a call tomorrow
and if you don't if you still haven't
received it we'll figure it out then
they she called me and she goes he
didn't get it it's okay well refund it
back but back to you sweet and I got a
full refund
to your door with with the cash that and
cookies here you go
that's amazing she was lifeless - yeah
well whatever you want we'll give it to
you David so I like your videos to thank
ya you tell Tim I said hi yes I can
[Music]